when there's certainly a shorthand we
have from you know having this been the
third film we've shot together now and
you don't spend a chunk of your shooting
time getting to know one another
you know we pick up where we left off
and have developed a great friendship
along the way and I don't like from the
beginning we were lucky we just had
chemistry in the same kind of enthusiasm
and you know I'd this the relationship I
look forward to you know it's really
delving into every time is being able to
ask the questions that for loci haven't
really had the acute focus to do so yet
and this instance was that you know that
was a great opportunity we had I Love
You Man it's absolutely true it's you
know from from the beginning of Kenneth
Branagh so all the way through Joss
Whedon's Avengers and into into Allen's
dark world it's it has been an amazing
adventure for both of us and and the two
characters define each other and need
each other and all acting is about what
happens in the space between people and
and and the more you trust each other
the deeper you can go and when I'm on
set with Chris whatever he serves I'll
return and he'll return them back and
and and that is the joy of it for me
another theme in this is that sibling
rivalry knows you've got two brothers
and I just wondered whether you drew a
relationship with them to inform your
interactions with Loki neither of them
have attempted to take over the universe
just yet but I think I don't have the
same reaction if I did what we're
competitive the siblings are and kind of
everything from sport and backyard
cricket football surfing to who's
controlling them I control watching TV
this industry not so much you know I
think we certainly all three of us
understand the sort of royalty and
inconsistency of you know had the work
and
you know we'd help each other with
auditions and always have and whatever
scripts are working on and you know
you're not direct competition anyway and
and and it's more of a kind of team
effort with this this than than anything
else one of the scenes uh where they're
you know in the spaceship sort of
exiting as God that Tom and I were
pretty insistent on saying no this has
got to feel like you know when you're in
the backseat with your siblings and you
know but we couldn't get a hundred
metres down the road before you know
certainly played into that thing and a
lot of the stuff you understand what
it's like to have that kind of height
sort of thing and you'd do anything for
them but the same time the simplest
things can annoy you and and yeah I
didn't certainly you know try and draw
from whatever experiences I've been
through or can empathize with
frustration towards one sibling I have
two sisters and I mean I suppose the
thing about siblings is is they they
know you they know you they know you
better than anyone and there's that that
thing of always being bound together by
your histories is is something there's
something very honest about the
interaction that you can't lie in front
of your your your siblings and I love in
the in this film I love that turn Thor
is able to to demand from low-key but he
play his hand he low-key someone who's
constantly in control he'll never show
you how he really feels in the only
person who gets close to it is four and
that seems very true of sibling
relationships and I absolutely second
the spaceship scene I've actually been
on a road trip with Chris and Liam
if you spend time with Luke Jesus is
like you just seem it knocks both their
heads together instead shut up cause
anything to go by and people really love
Lukey what do you think it is about loci
that people seem to really love seven
more years of Brotherly but I don't know
that it was ever the plan to have Loki
in this many films but purely to do with
everything that Tom brought to the table
in the first one and how incredible he
was and the the mixture of of strength
and villainous and mischief and and
vulnerability which is such an access
point you can immediately kind of
empathize with this misunderstood guy
he's why he was kept you know if my
correct Kevin why he kept bringing him
back into every film like I don't know
that was ever the plan but I mean my hat
goes off to Salman and I think he's done
such an incredible job in every film and
hopefully we can keep sneaking him in
you know I wanted to say it in response
to the second bite
I think Loki is defined by Thor he's
defined in opposition to him that they
are yin and yang they are the sort of
the Sun in the moon that the whole point
of them is that they are in opposition
and the whole sort of firm I don't know
the popularity of the character has been
such an amazing surprise I had never
expected it in my wildest dreams and I
don't know I found him a fascinating
prospect because
he's a mixture of of playfulness and Tom
and mischief
that's his moniker he's the god of
mischief so there's a playfulness to him
but he's such a broken but broken
character he's grief-stricken and bitter
and jealous and angry and lonely and
proud and so the cocktail of all of his
kind of psychological damage and and his
playfulness as an actor is just a really
interesting thing to inhabit and by the
way you are the only thought Malekith is
the main enemy in this so Loki
he's although he's seen as the enemy
he's not the main antagonist Homer I'm
deep down do you think Loki is really
evil or is it too jealous to start on
the outside it's it's it's a question
that I've asked myself three times you
know I think yeah every villain is a
hero in his own mind and people make
choices and and they always justify
those choices no matter how misguided
their motivation and and the great
privilege and thrill for me to play this
character across three films is is is
that he didn't start out that way and
and the storyline the narrative that was
afforded to me in the very first film
this idea of a young prince who was
brought up believing in his son his
right to a throne his inheritance of his
and his Asgard inheritance that this
whole story was a lie that he was
adopted and and left to die a frozen
rock and that that essentially is is
what breaks his heart and all of this is
villainy all of his sir his bad guy
credentials come from something deeply
vulnerable and
that's a gift because it means across
across across Avengers across the dark
world that I can play a dynamic with
Chris and with adds new options in Rio
Russo which is to what extent is he
redeemable can he be pulled back towards
the light and it's a very very fun fault
line to dance on
you